bulgaria's prime minister hasn't given
any interviews in this election campaign
just photo opportunities where the only
camera allowed
is from his own team boyco borisov
governs an eu country where
according to the u.s state department
there's little judicial independence
there are arbitrary arrests and
journalists are threatened with violence
in sunday's election he could well
retain his grip on this former satellite
of the soviet union
it takes long for democratic attitudes
to mature
but on the other hand there are concrete
uh
experiences of the bulgarians over the
past three decades and
the fact that they have not been been
able to reap the benefits
that a democratic system in theory
should provide so they have become
disenchanted more of the polled
bulgarians that
say 45 percent would prefer a model of
strongmen leadership last summer several
months of anti-corruption protests were
the biggest challenge to borisov
they started after an opposition leader
tried to set foot on a public beach
that had been sealed off for use by one
of bulgaria's most powerful men
bristow ivanov says the eu ignores the
corruption here
because borisov's party is allied with
the largest
centre-right coalition in the european
parliament
is not an ideologue he doesn't uh sort
of
make any political pronouncing he is a
silent practitioner
of authoritarianism of corruption the
european people's party the the elite in
brussels and in berlin frankly
we need to understand that they they
cannot afford any longer to
close that to term blind eye to what is
happening in sofia
any protests now are tiny in comparison
that's part fears of covid part
resignation
and a former prime minister says the eu
ignores at its peril
what is happening here the transparency
of use of the funds has to be put
on a new rules it came
that the abundance of the financing from
european union
became a source for corruption not for
development of the country
the european commission says corruption
is a major obstacle to development in
bulgaria
the latest polls give the prime
minister's party around a 28
share of the vote the opposition
socialists are trailing around eight
percent
behind political experts here say there
could be
a government of national unity if that's
the case then boycott borisov
as head of the largest party will keep
his job
as prime minister bernard smith al
jazeera
sofia